[Music]
this is tango
she's a yellow-headed amazon an
extremely intelligent personable and
talkative parrot
i think tango is uncharacteristically
quiet today
native to mexico and northwestern
central america adult yellow-headed
amazons are identified by you guessed it
their full yellow heads the rest of
their body is green with some yellow and
red visible on the bend of their wings
[Music]
they make their homes in forests and
wooded areas and subsist on a diet of
fruits berries nuts and seeds
the yellow-headed amazon has been a
prized pet parrot for centuries lively
volleyball birds they can hold an
impressive vocabulary which only
contributes to their demand
although captive-bred yellow-headed
amazons can be owned they continue to be
poached illegally in the wild which is
why they're endangered over the past two
decades only their numbers outside of
captivity have plummeted to a tenth of
its former population making their
situation precarious
this is the yellow-headed amazon
[Music]
you